hey everyone
welcome to this series on angular in
this video
we'll create a simple hello world
application and take a tour of the
packages and modules in an angular app
but before we begin if you love watching
tech videos and want to keep yourself
updated with cutting edge technologies
then subscribe to our channel and hit
the bell icon
so now without further ado let's look at
the agenda for the session
first we'll see a brief introduction to
angular
then we look at the prerequisites to
build an angular app
and finally we have a demo on the
creation of your first application
all right so what exactly is angular
now i'm sure you all have apps like
instagram youtube and facebook at your
fingertips
now one of the reasons why everybody
loves them so much
is because they offer a seamless user
interface
now angular helps us with that so what
exactly is angular
it is a javascript framework mainly used
for building spas
or single page applications these single
page applications get loaded initially
and all the subsequent interactions only
update the additional data
on the screen the entire page doesn't
get reloaded
so i hope you understood what a single
page application is
so angular is developed using typescript
which is the superset of javascript now
you must be wondering
why angular angular as a framework
provides a few significant advantages
while also providing a common structure
for developers on a team to work with
now coming to the advantages first up
this custom components
now angular allows you to build your own
declarative components
that can render logic into reusable
pieces
data binding angular allows you to
seamlessly move your data
from your code javascript code to the
view don't worry in the subsequent
videos we'll discuss this in detail
next up we have dependency injection now
angular allows you to write modular
components
and have them injected wherever needed
this greatly improves the testability
and reusability of the code
next up is testing now angular has been
built from the ground up
with testability in mind so you can
practically test every part of your
application
lastly it's comprehensive angular is a
full-fledged framework and provides
out-of-the-box solutions for server
communication routing with your
application
and more so moving on let's look at the
prerequisites for angular
first up we have node.js angular uses
node.js
as its base for a large part of its
build environment
so as a result to get started with
angular you will need to have node.js
installed on your environment
so head to your official website and
download the latest release
for your corresponding operating system
next up is the angular cli
now this command line interface is a
tool that makes it easier to bootstrap
and develop your angular applications
now to install the latest version run
the command
npm install hyphen g at angular
front slash cli you got gotta run this
command on your command prompt
and finally to confirm installation
check for its version
now the next thing that you will need is
an ide or a text editor to type your
code
now there are several ides that you can
choose from but in this
series we've used vs code throughout so
it is available on all platforms
so go ahead and download it if you
haven't already now moving on to the
final part
is the demo now that you have a basic
understanding of angular and its
prerequisites
i think you're ready to create your
first angular application
so let's head to our vs code and begin
here i've created a folder called
angular on my desktop
and opened it on my visual studio code
so to create our app
you need to open the terminal just go
here and
select new terminal
and now type in the command ng
new and provide the name for your app
so i'm just going to say hello world so
now this is going to create
just say yes so basically what happens
is that when you run the command
it will automatically generate a
skeleton application under the folder
that is hello world in our case
and it includes a bunch of files and
installs all the necessary dependencies
for the angular application
so this could take a while
so once you've created your application
to run it first change the directory so
let's say hello world
and now use the command ng serve
now once it's compiled you need to go to
your browser
and type in localhost 4200
and once you do that you can see your ui
you can see that the application has
been loaded onto your browser
and it says hello world app is running
so this is how you create your
application so let's go back to our vs
code
now as you can see here there are many
files and folders that are created right
so let's look at a few of them of course
we can't explain everything
but i'll rush through a few of them so
the first main component is basically
the root component
now the root component here is the
index.html
so here if you open the file and see
it's a very small crisp code right but
the most important thing in the file
is this app root element so what this
does is it's basically the marker for
loading your application code
so this is extremely important so the
next important
file is the main.ts now this is the part
of the bootstrapping piece
all right so the index.html file is
responsible for deciding
which files are to be loaded correct the
main.ts file on the other hand
identifies which angular module is to be
loaded when the application starts
so this is just a brief explanation as
to what they are doing
next we have the app folder now here
we have the app.module.ts file
now this application module file can be
thought of as the code configuration of
your application
so here's where the source code starts
from and moving on we have
the app.component.ts so these are all
typescript files hence the extension ts
now this file basically is a root
component of your application
and then we have the html file for the
same which defines the appearance of
what you can see on your browser
so let me just change the message that
is being displayed
so i'll say hey
welcome to this angular
tutorial so let's save this and when we
go back to our browser
we can see the message hey welcome to
this angular tutorial being displayed
so like this we can make a simple change
and then it gets rendered onto your
browser
so this was just a brief explanation of
what happens in the background of your
application
i hope it was helpful to you so with
that we conclude this session
we will be back with more videos on
angular so watch out for them
until then keep learning and stay tuned
to simply learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here